et voilà
quoi oui il est en train de divorcer
alors appelle-le c'est rien c'est pas
parler depuis des années les amis c'est
fait pour ça
tu vas
mettre brasseur dans mon propre
établissement
qu'est-ce que tu fais de beau
on est jeune brunch non j'ai pas le
temps pour ça tu peux pas être ami avec
une fille
célèbres qui sont amis non laura Dern et
sa Menil dans Jurassic Park
[Applaudissements]
c'est typiquement ce que vit une femme à
ce moment-là on dirait deux adolescentes
vous savez toujours eu une relation
massaise et destructrice notre relation
n'est pas destructrice que je sache
elle dit n'importe quoi
j'aime pas sentir que je suis le
deuxième homme le plus important de ta
vie
devant toi oui et encore plus perdu que
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de ma vie
[Applaudissements]
comment va ta vie j'ai mis beaucoup de
maquillage et de fond de teint ça se
voit vraiment super
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]